babies bounty will be providing diapers
and supplies to ukrainian refugees in
poland in wake of the ongoing invasion
from russia they're asking for our
community's help and donations trying to
reach a goal of one hundred thousand
dollars as of now the nonprofit already
has five pallets of diapers and supplies
ready to ship off and each pallet is
about 16 000 diapers rather kelly
maxwell the executive director of baby's
bounty says the situation in ukraine has
left her heartbroken and she wanted to
take action any way she could
that feeling of helplessness when you
watch something happening across the
world
doesn't settle well with me so i wanted
to help where i could and i know diapers
the hope is that these supplies will be
delivered to refugees in the next coming
weeks if you would like to donate to the
cause you can stop by their location on
desert inn or go to the link up on our
website 8newsnow.com as for supplies new
baby blankets are in high demand right
now